al jazeera's invited on a tour a
showcase of combined u.s and philippine
fire power
here in the northern province of kagayan
550 kilometers from taiwan a scenario is
being played out the philippine marines
are defending the country's coastal
waters from imagined foreign incursions
with the help of american troops
it is a test of combat readiness
in tarlac another northern philippine
province
large-scale drills of live fire
maneuvers and aircraft assaults are held
that is to ensure that the american and
philippine military capabilities are
synchronized in the event of an armed
attack this is how balikatan or shoulder
to shoulder exercises look up close
certainly the objective of what we're
doing is
demonstrating the strength of the
alliance
as well as the commitment to regional
security and that is the purpose of this
exercise
the balikatan is one of the most visible
manifestations of the mutual defense
treaty which was signed in 1951 and this
year's exercise is proving to be one of
its biggest with nearly nine thousand
soldiers from both countries
with the philippines and china both
claiming the spratly islands and beijing
and regional neighbors also claiming
other disputed islands and reefs
tensions have been raised in a region
already considered a possible security
flashpoint
some officials say the philippine
military needs to beef up its coastal
defense capabilities
if we talk of external aggression
because
sabina and we count 53 years that we've
been doing
for audito salon
so it's high time nasigura with the
unfolding events
and internationally this year's
exercises show how far president rodrigo
duterte has walked back on his initial
promise to scale down u.s military
activities in the country
with growing tensions in the south china
sea both the u.s and the philippine
military say they need to stay alert
and any military that fails to evolve
over time will eventually fail to defend
its own nation
jamella
province northern philippines